Oh, so the wife and I are watching
Christmas Chronicles with Kurt Russell as a singing
Santa, right. We're having a good time.
Then the movie introduce
something truly terrifying elves.
That was it. Movie night was over.
I couldn't watch anymore.
I was done. Oh, here we go.
What's your problem with elves game?
Well, the problem is that the elves looks
almost real, but not quite almost natural, but
not quite. And it was upsetting.
I mean, have you ever seen an animation
and felt a little bit creeped out?
I'm looking at you, Polar Express.
Well, or have you ever seen a mannequin or a
robot or even a wax dummy that was very
lifelike but still looked wrong?
Sounds like you're describing a Silicon Valley
CEO, robotic and lifelike, but not human
yet to the point where it's uncomfortable even
looking at them, much less being around
them now, huh? Yeah,
they're awkward to watch.
I think we've been going now
for just under two hours.
This anxiety is called Uncanny Valley and everyone
experiences it, though some of us are
less tolerant than others.
Oh, let me guess. You are not very tolerant.
You are correct. I am very susceptible
to Uncanny Valley and I'm not alone.
Let's find out why. Welcome to the
Y files, we're smart folks like us
come to laugh and learn today we're going to
talk about Uncanny Valley and why we feel so
anxious when we experience it.
So let's start with the uncanny part.
Uncanny is used to describe something that's
almost identical or almost perfect, but not
quite there. And that's what's
happening with Uncanny Valley.
Think of the movie scene where the
CGI was almost human, but not quite.
How did that make you
feel? A bit uneasy, right?
I remember Polar Express.
This movie has become a legendary bomb and
most people agree it's because the animation
style landed right in the
middle of Uncanny Valley.
The problem comes when something artificial, like
a robot animation statue or even a
painting depicts the human form.
Realistically, we're OK up to a certain point
of realism because our brain can clearly
tell us that the imitation is exactly that.
An imitation we're uncanny.
Valley starts to form is when we get too
close to reality, but not quite close enough.
If you were to plot realism against
psychological acceptance, the curve moves steadily up
and then falls off a cliff.
That's the valley. And we'll get more into the
science of this as the video goes along.
So with the hard lessons learned from
Polar Express, Animation Studios began test
screening their films.
When the final cut of Shrek was
screened, the Princess Fiona character actually reduced
children to tears.
Children screaming in fear is not funny.
It depends on the context you see.
Fair enough. So to fix the Princess Fiona
problem, the studio actually went back and made
Shrek feel less lifelike in
order to avoid traumatizing children.
Computer games are also becoming more realistic,
and they can blur the line between
virtual reality and actual reality.
And game designers are very aware of Uncanny
Valley, and they work hard to avoid it.
The term Uncanny Valley was first hypothesized
in 1970 by Japanese roboticist Masahiro
Mori, who identified that as robots became more
and more human like people found them to
be more acceptable and appealing
than their mechanical counterparts.
But this only held true up to a point when
they were close to but not quite human people
developed a sense of unease and discomfort.
Take Shrek, for example.
Most people remember this movie as
a fun frolic through fantasy land.
Hated it. Hated if you want.
Most people loved it cheap.
Anyway, Shrek hit the sweet spot that
Mori was hinting at in his hypothesis.
When Princess Fiona looked almost human, she was scary
as hell, but make her more like a
cartoon. Suddenly she's likeable.
You say likeable, likeable.
So if it wasn't for that test screening
and the identification of characters that were
landing in Uncanny Valley, Shrek
might never have happened.
We would have been fine without it.
People love Shrek.
Sheep Movie on modern robotics provides the
most context for Uncanny Valley, which makes
sense considering the term
originated from that field.
We've all seen robots that are made to
be as lifelike as possible, but we get
uncomfortable when they move unnaturally or have
kind of lifeless eyes, very cool, upsy
corpsing, quartzite like a dead body.
I know what a corpse is.
I didn't like that thing in your
closet you bought from the Internet.
Oh, there's nothing in my closet.
Oh, come on. You UNAM is on track and you
ought like every 15 minutes until it got here,
you kept staring at the
window like a puppy dog.
There's nothing in my closet.
You know, if you never saw
that thing, they'd call a cat.
There's nothing in my closet.
Right, right, right. There's no room for
anything else with all the skeletons.
Any engineers are very aware of Uncanny Valley,
so they work hard to avoid it.
Take Osmo, the Honda
designed upright Android.
Asimo is very human that it can walk, run,
play soccer, do all kinds of other stuff.
But Asimo doesn't creep us out.
A primary reason that people love this robot and
don't fear it is because while ASIMO is
designers have replicated a lot of human
behavior, they haven't tried to replicate too
many human physical features.
Asimo is clearly a robot, a
simple machine and nothing more.
Now, it might seem counterintuitive, but something
that acts human but looks artificial
is much more agreeable than something
that looks human and acts artificial.
It is very nice to meet you.
Much more agreeable.
Asimo doesn't fall into Uncanny Valley, but
put a human head on the thing.
Suddenly it's a horror movie
Shrek is still worth.
If we haven't earned a subscription today, I
promise this moron's going to keep making
these stupid videos. And so is Uncanny Valley
just a scientific theory or is it something
innate in all of us?
It appears as though it's something all
humans share with varying degrees of severity.
But it's been scientifically proven.
Academics Maya Mather and David Reichling studied 80
real world robots and found a clear
value effect and how much people liked and
were willing to trust each individual robot.
It was essentially a ranking exercise from
least creepy to most participants were asked
to rank which robots they would trust to
invest one hundred dollars of their money.
It turns out that the robots that were
closest to human form close to the valley
threshold, they weren't getting a dollar.
The participants didn't trust them.
But the robots that just looked like
robots, they were deemed more trustworthy.
Real, no, real. I don't
know what that means, Greg.
If scientists agree that Uncanny Valley does
indeed exist, where is the valley?
It's thought that Uncanny Valley might occur
at the boundary where something moves from
one category to another.
In this case between nonhuman and human
psychologist Christine Luser and Thalia Wheatly
looked at mannequin faces and found the
uneasy tipping point to where the mannequins
looked to Lifelike.
Come on. Now, mannequins are definitely creepy,
but we tolerate them in the normal
context of using them to display clothes.
But take a minute to think about a
mannequin in a department store not wearing clothes.
Are we going to address
what's in your closet now?
No, no, no, no, no, no. We've moved on.
Many people find
undressed mannequins disconcerting.
Now, imagine if they showed signs of life.
Yikes, what Looser and Wheatly showed is that
there's definitely a point of no return
where a robot or artificial human appeared
to show actual human consciousness, we jump
into Uncanny Valley when we believe a robot
can reason, learn and feel like humans do.
You know, I'm afraid of robots.
Yeah, with artificial intelligence improving as quickly
as it is, it's no wonder that
this is a concern. A study by researchers
Kurt Gray and Daniel Wegner found that robots
were only unnerving when people thought they
had the ability to sense and experience
things. If people felt like robots couldn't reason
on their own, they didn't seem as
frightening. We fear artificial life is
having human like consciousness without the
control that humans have, essentially.
We worry that they're going to go on
terminated Matrix AI and Giant write a robot,
Robocop, Westworld, Westworld again.
Ok, Metropolis A.I., The Stepford Wives.
Got it. It becomes self-aware to 4:00 a.m.
Eastern Time, August 29th.
Of course, Uncanny Valley only occurs if we
can tell that these things are artificial.
Once we cross the valley entirely and we
perceive something or someone to be fully human,
we then become more comfortable because we
consciously or subconsciously perceive them as
actually human, even if we know they're not.
I prefer the term artificial person myself.
Creating artificial life that makes the leap
over Uncanny Valley is beyond our current
state of engineering, but it's
definitely on the horizon.
Obviously, this brings up all sorts of
anxieties into what's real or not.
Then there is the old Blade Runner conundrum as
to whether something is a robot or not.
Is this testing whether I'm
a replicant or a lesbian?
Mr. Dekker, just answer
the questions, please.
There's also a theory that robots and I could
learn to cross Uncanny Valley on their own
without human intervention.
Now, this happens. Is that consciousness?
Is that self-awareness?
These questions start to veer
into philosophy and existentialism.
Please, though, we're not doing
it now, thank goodness.
But we have a video
coming up on consciousness.
So hit subscribe in the bell
and all the fancy buttons.
You'll be notified when it's ready.
I'd rather watch Shrek.
Another trigger for Uncanny Valley is seeing
behavior that contradicts expected emotion or
lack of emotion altogether,
which reads robotic.
Angela Tinnell has led studies in virtual
characters exploring these mismatches of emotion
and behavior, and one study looked at the lack
of surprise in a character's upper half of
the face where the lower half had a reaction
in this caused all sorts of eeriness and led
to these characters to develop similar
mannerisms to that of psychopaths.
Humans can recognize these
facial patterns automatically.
Take a look at someone who's smiling
sincerely versus someone who's smiling insincerely.
You'll notice that with a sincere smile, muscles
of the entire face move, especially the
eyes. When someone is being insincere, only the
muscles of the lower half of the face
move. There has been further research into
the jarring experience of having animated
characters reacting with mismatched features and emotion,
all of which left some pretty
horrible feelings in the minds of the
subjects, even though they were obviously watching
something animated differences between eyes and
other features were especially bad.
Turns out a happy smile and angry eyes is
not a good look and pushes the unfortunate
recipient of this expression
headfirst into the valley.
So what's the purpose of this reaction?
Well, the answer is debatable, but it's
generally thought of as a self-preservation
response encoded in our
DNA through evolution.
Uncanny Valley helps us perceive threats by
detecting insincere emotions and could be a
way for us to avoid people we
may perceive as physically or emotionally ill.
It's pretty clear that we're getting closer
and closer to inventing robots and artificial
intelligence that are indistinguishable
from human life.
So how will we know when we've
built a bridge across Uncanny Valley?
Will no time to talk about that closet.
Thanks for hanging out with us today.
My name is A.J. That's Hellfish.
This has been the Y files.
You have any good examples of Uncanny Valley?
Post them in the comments section so
we can all have panic attacks.
We're working hard for you.
So do us a favor. Give us a thumbs up.
And if we have an earn your subscription
today, I promise we'll keep making fun, brainy
content until we do our hit.
Until next time, be safe, be kind
and know that you are appreciated.